um that your new album how would you
describe it as uh just sonically
compared to you know something else
um sonically I would say uh
um
it's just very different man we're just
trying I just explore a lot of new
worlds places that I've never really
been before and like
well maybe some places I tried to go
before and I wasn't too comfortable in
those spaces like for example something
like rummy drop like I had a song called
rummy drop one of my second album and uh
I wasn't really I was nervous about
doing a song like that
um now I have a song that's kind of like
that but um you know I'm a lot more
confident in that space and you know you
can just tell you can hear it you can
feel it so
um there's a lot of confidence through
others throughout this album and uh yeah
do you feel like because I feel like Nas
went through this with Illmatic 50 went
through it with get rich or die trying
where like you put out an album like
trap soul and like people just want
another one of those yeah that's the
worst right and because that happened
with nas I mean like if you look back to
NASA's second album It Was Written it's
a [ __ ] perfect project in my opinion
but when it first came out people were
like yo this ain't Illmatic what the
[ __ ] is this you know what I'm saying do
you feel like
is that a gift the gift in the cursed
part of having a project like trap soul
and especially it's your first project
right it just made it even more right
yeah crazy
um
the way I see it now is I'm just like
man it's it's there for you to listen to
it because I can listen to it yeah Jay-Z
said it best like Nick can I say uh say
what you want [ __ ] want my old [ __ ]
about my old album yeah simple as that
like you want if you want that go get it
Tyler Creator said something like a tool
you said something along the lines of
like yo go get it from the source while
I get the the you know the reproduced
version or whatever like you know I mean
it's pure over here so just go listen to
that you know what I mean and if your
favorite artist or whoever it is that
you support and ain't putting out
anything else like that then should I
guess go find another artist to listen
to yes yeah I also think too like you
got to grow man like at the end of the
day right like you said you've seen
places because you didn't see before you
recorded your first album so you wanna
you've lived a lot of life yeah I mean I
have 100